alexis foule un bonjour alors le conseil
d'état a donc validé hier l'extension du
pasa sanitaires il émet quelques
réserves cependant est ce surprenant
selon vous cette validation par les
sages hélas non on voit que depuis le
début de cette crise sanitaire conseil
constitutionnel conseil d'état
accompagnant les mesures liberticides de
sans coup férir on a l'impression que
l'état de droit est suspendue depuis
mars 2020 et ça ne fait qu'empirer
alors on pouvait s'attendre peut-être à
davantage de deux mises en demeure ou de
questions ça a été le cas sur la
surveillance par drones ou par quelques
quelques autres mesures qu'ont tenté de
faire passer le gouvernement et la
majorité l'a visiblement tout passe sauf
bien sûr les centres commerciaux parce
qu'il ya eu là sur le lobbies des
centres commerciaux les syndicats qui
ont dit que c'était impossible de
contrôler et de cette façon là alors on
se retrouve avec cet outil totalement
ubuesque un qui va donc faire que les
français vont être obligés de montrer
leur passé ni terre pour prendre un
verre en terrasse mais pas pour entrer
dans le métro pas pour aller dans un
centre commercial tout ça continue
finalement sont très peu de questions de
la part de ceux qui font le droit et
c'est inquiétant parce que en 5ème
république il ya très peu de contre
pouvoirs et si ceux là sont inopérants
alors on voit bien que les libertés
tombent les unes après les autres sous
bien sûr un une idée de faire quelque
chose de salutaire mais je vois pas ce
qu'il ya de sanitaires dans un passé
aussi ubuesque aussi difficile à
appliquer ou finalement on va demander à
chacun une transparence de chaque
instant alors même que le chef de l'état
qui avait promis un de publier ses
bilans de santé lors de la campagne de
2017 n'a publié qu'une fois un bilan de
santé c'est lorsqu'il a eu qu'ovide
l'hiver 2020 donc lui disait qu'il
fallait respecter
bien sûr le secret médical pour le
président comme pour tous les français
ce n'est plus le cas pour tous les
français maintenant ils doivent être
transparents s'ils veulent aller au
cinéma dans une salle de spectacle à la
bibliothèque ou prendre le train c'est
totalement inacceptable en réalité si on
réfléchi une seconde
ce n'a aucune raison d'être et c'est
surtout extrêmement dangereux puisque
aucune garantie n'est donnée sur la
durée
bien sûr de ce pass sanitaires aussi
longtemps que nécessaire nous dit
gabriela talent mais qu'est ce que ça
veut dire en réalité ça pourrait durer
puisque l'état d'urgence
il va être prolongée encore jusqu'en
décembre de cette année donc c'est
extrêmement inquiétant et ce qui est
inquiétant c'est que ceux qui sont là
pour garantir la constitution et le
droit ne sont plus leur travail
le pass annie terre qui à partir de
demain donc un devrait être présenté
dans les lieux de culture ou de loisirs
là où il ya plus de 50 personnes
gabriella talent a parlé d'une période
de rodage à votre avis qu'est ce que
cela veut dire comment est ce que cela
pourrait se passer justement
oui alors c'est encore une fois le
runtime acronis et un bas côté on a un
gabriel atta le porte parole qui parle
d'une période de rodage
là encore pas établie il dit ce sera une
semaine n'est pas un mois et puis les
questions d'accompagner de ne pas
censurer les établissements pour la mise
en place de ce pass sanitaires et puis
le en même temps vous avez une mise de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin qui a
demandé une extrême fermeté de la part
des forces de l'ordre pour contrôler
espace sanitaire délai de 21
donc ça va être encore un cafouillage ça
va être encore à la tête du client ça va
être encore du grand n'importe quoi avec
des montants d'amande qui ne sont encore
pas établi je crois on parlait de 45000
euros pour un établissement c'est
inacceptable évidemment des peines de
prison on est quand même dans ces
moments assez particulier puisque si
vous êtes positif ces dix jours à
l'isolément avec la possibilité que la
police vienne nous voir donc si ça c'est
plus un état quasiment totalitaire je ne
sais pas ce que c'est mais ce n'est plus
du tout à l'état on fait ce qu'on veut
alors je veux bien que le virus il a bon
dos virus c'est vrai nous sommes dans
une quatrième vague il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de contamination mais pour le
moment l'hôpital n'est pas engorgés et
je vois qu'on va dépenser des milliards
2,2 milliards de doses de vaccins qui
sont commandés pour 2022 2023 pour 70
millions de français environ donc avec
une assure qu'au vaccin pourront donner
aux pays pauvres
ça fait plus de 40 milliards qui vont
être dépensés dans des vaccins 40
milliards qui ne sont pas investis dans
l'hôpital qui ne sont pas investis dans
le recrutement de nouveaux soignants qui
ne sont pas investis finalement pour
pérenniser et puis il faut savoir aussi
que cette majorité ce président a été
contre la levée des brevets sur les sur
les vaccins donc on est là vraiment dans
un système de vases clos où beaucoup
d'argent va se faire sur ce produit ce
vaccin qui permet d'avoir des formes
moins graves atténué mais qui ne permet
pas d'éviter le coc vide ni de le
transmettre
donc je ne comprends pas en fait la
logique dans laquelle nous sommes
rentrés si ce n'est
celle d'un choix pris par la rapidité
parce qu'il faut relancer l'économie
coûte que coûte et parce que visiblement
nos dirigeants ont choisi cette solution
alors que partout ailleurs que ce soit
avant ou ou en grande bretagne
les qr codes l'epa sanitaires ont été
mis à la poubelle parce que ça ne
fonctionnait pas parce que ça ne servait
à rien finalement pour lutter contre
l'épidémie
on marche à contre courant on marche sur
la tête en france dernière question très
rapidement alexis à poulain le
gouvernement parle de course contre le
variant delta est finalement une course
en avant liberticide complètement c'est
ce que je disais à l'instant on voit
bien que derrière chaque mesure a été
acceptée les confinements lesotho
autorisation de sorte qu'ils soient les
tests les trouva finalement comme si à
chaque fois on a pu tuer les français à
davantage de contrôles à davantage de
mesures qui les privait de liberté qu'il
est plaisant travail dans leur quotidien
hélas le pass sanitaires il est non
acceptée on voit bien qu'il y avait
énormément de monde dans les rues 1
samedi dernier il ya beaucoup d'appels à
manifester devant l'assemblée nationale
même dès mercredi dès samedi prochain
avec un mélange hétéroclite un de gens
qui viennent de toutes les familles
politiques pour défendre justement les
libertés parce que aucune garantie n'est
donnée sur l'utilisation de se passe sur
le long terme sur la durée de ce pass et
surtout sur la raison d'être de ce passe
quand les autres pays européens ne le
font pas donc c'est extrêmement
inquiétant de voir qu'on a un pays qui
s'est habitué à voir la police qui
valait contrôler pour prendre un verre
en terrasse
c'est pas normal on devrait se réveiller
rapidement parce que ce pass sanitaire
c'est vraiment l'ouverture d'une
citoyenneté à plusieurs vitesses avec
les bons et les mauvais citoyens ce qui
se vaccinent ceux qui n'ont pas ce
qu'ils jouent le jeu ceux qui ne jouent
pas le jeu alors même que nous ne savons
pas quelle va être l'ampleur du variant
delta même si les alarmistes un parle
bien sûr de nombreuses contaminations
aujourd'hui encore une fois les services
d'urgence ne sont pas engorger comme
c'était le cas lors des vagues
précédentes donc vraiment attention
quand on voit les pouvoirs cas emmanuel
macron dans la vème république et
l'absence de contre-pouvoir
c'est aux français maintenant je crois
de défendre vraiment leur liberté et
leur capacité aussi à se protéger non
pas du virus mais dans une dérive
autoritaire du pouvoir
merci beaucoup a laissé répondre à la
question je rappelle que vous êtes
la liste